I think developments in artificial intelligence
do pose a strong challenge for humanity.
I think at a very fundamental level people
don't quite understand what artificial intelligence
is yet it's used as a buzzword that's going
to solve every single problem.
You sort of have either the very binary sort
of treatment of - it's all wonderful, it's
all great, and it's going to solve every problem.
Or you have "robot armies are going to kill
everyone."
I think the first challenge that we have is
even the vocabulary that we use to talk about
developments in AI. see a lot of people in
Asia - and also elsewhere in the world to
be fair - who use words like "algorithms,"
"big data," "analytics," "artificial intelligence,"
to all mean pretty much the same thing.
They use them as interchangeable synonyms,
and I think that does all of these technologies
a disservice because they're not necessarily
the same thing.
You can have automation that is not AI-driven.
You can also have AI that is not just about
automation.
So I think it's a technology or a set of technologies
that on some level are very very opaque and
inscrutable, yet they're being talked about
as if it's the most common, obvious, everyday,
ubiquitous thing.
Really what we're trying to do is look at
the impact of AI, specifically on Asian countries,
and I think even within Asia it's not a monolithic
thing of - "all of Asia is going to be treated
the same way or is going to react the same
way."
I think within Asia you have countries that
are going to be early adopters of AI, that
are very geared up to advance technologies.
So countries like Korea, Japan, Hong Kong,
Singapore are probably going to be a little
better equipped.
And I think a lot of the poorer developing,
emerging economies are not quite there yet.
I don't think they quite understand what's
going to hit them, when it does.
And I think there's a huge role for academia
to play in all of this.
To make sure that in the way that it develops
that it's something that has an ethical backbone,
that is implemented responsibly, that has
all the right stakeholders involved in the
decisionmaking about how these technologies
are deployed.
And I think that really needs to be a very,
very robust conversation.
It's not the technology companies setting
the standards and governments and academics
and social scientists having no say in how
this happens.